[Musica]
negli anni trenta del 1800 un giovane
biologo salva su una nave e un
brigantino inglese che deve attraversare
modo fare il giro del mondo a scopo
scientifico
arrivato sulle coste del madagascar
questo biologo la sua la sua curiosità
viene attratta da questo fiore
un'orchidea che ha una particolarità lo
sperone nettarifere che la parte dove
fioretti ha nel nettare particolarmente
allungato 23 cm
tornato in patria pubblica un diario e
in cui scrive che secondo lui su
quest'isola ci deve essere una farfalla
che abbia un aspiro tromba cioè la bocca
della farfalla che usa per prendere
mettere dei fiori di adeguata lunghezza
questo all'epoca era un azzardo nessuno
aveva mai studiato una farfalla che
avesse la spiro tromba più lunga del
proprio corpo
quarant'anni dopo
una seconda spedizione trova questa
farfalla probabilmente alcuni di voi
l'avranno intuito questo giorno giovane
biologo altri non era che un 25enne
charles darwin non ho trovato una foto
di lui 25enne credo che qui ne abbiamo
una ottantina di anni darvin all'epoca
appunto aveva fatto un azzardo aveva
fatto una scommessa perché vi parlo di
questa storia vi parlo di questa storia
perché parla di due argomenti che io
voglio trattare stasera 1 e come noi
creiamo senso dalla realtà e l'altro è
come funzionano ea cosa servono le
storie questi due argomenti per la
psicologia e la semiotica contemporanea
sono in realtà strettamente le delegati
se non addirittura la stessa identica
cosa andiamo a vedere la storia di darvi
in più da vicino darvi insieme su di
fronte alla complessità che era parola
d'ordine di oggi del mondo naturale
nello specifico delle coste del
madagascar e la sua mente ha selezionato
alcuni tratti distintivi in base alla
sua curiosità e li ha ordinati secondo
un pensile scolandoli anche ovviamente
con le sue conoscenze precedenti in un
pensiero
che ha la forma e la struttura identica
a quello di una storia questa narrazione
ha prodotto per lui del senso lo scopo
finale di tutto questo lavoro è la
predittività
darwin è morto senza aver visto quella
farfalla ma sapendo che una farfalla
così ci doveva essere a questo servono
in primis le storie sono uno strumento
del nostro cervello per creare
significato il nostro cervello prende la
realtà che è complessa e la trasforma in
qualcosa di complicato che può essere
quindi spiegato
che gli possono essere tolte le pieghe
può essere quindi spiegato ma se voi ci
pensa te le storie non sono solo questo
per noi anzi più intuitivamente le
storie per noi sono uno strumento per
condividere significato
ci sembra una banalità
nel senso che noi lo facciamo con grande
naturalezza ma noi siamo gli unici
animali in grado di farlo noi
condividiamo significato complesso che
il nostro cervello ci prepara in questi
pacchetti di significato e li possiamo
tramandare ad altri della nostra specie
siamo gli unici animali a poterlo fare
questa unicità poter tramandare senso
complesso questa unicità ha fatto dire
ad uno storico contemporaneo yuval noah
rari che le storie sono anche un'altra
cosa sono cioè il principale strumento
evoluzionistico nell'arsenale
dell'umanità sono quella cosa che ci ha
messi su quella che lui chiama la corsia
di sorpasso dell'evoluzione che ci ha
fatti diventare la specie predominante
sul pianeta superando tutte le altre
in che senso
uno strumento evoluzionistico vi faccio
un esempio pratico se voi siete una
scimmia stata in un gruppo di scimmie
composto di 100 150 massimo 500 elementi
per un motivo molto semplice voi per
fidarvi degli altri li dovete conoscere
uno per uno
noi non funzioniamo così gli uomini
vivono in gruppi che sono infinitamente
più grandi di cui non conoscono la
maggior parte delle persone che ne fanno
che ne fanno parte i gruppi più grandi
risolvono problemi più complessi
in che senso le storie tengono uniti
gruppi vi faccio di nuovo un esempio
pratico se voi siete uno juventino
sfegatato e andate al mare e il tizio di
fianco a voi stende un asciugamano su
cui c'è un grosso logo della juve in un
in un istante senza scambiare una parola
voi sapete che con quella persona
condividete uno storico una storia di
gioie e di dolori ultimamente poi
particolarmente che fa sì che con quella
persona ci sia una una base per la
collaborazione e la fiducia reciproca
se ci pensate
il mondo simbolico il mondo delle storie
umano è vastissimo non finisce allo
stadio ogni ambito della nostra vita a
una storia che lo regola
la le religioni sono storie il la
nazionalità se domani l'italia
sprofondasse nel mediterraneo noi
resteremo gli italiani il denaro se ci
pensate una storia che ha deciso che un
foglio con su scritto 5 euro valga 5
euro una narrazione condivisa che fa sì
che se io vado da uno che vende panini e
gli do 5 euro lui mi dà un panino in
cambio sapendo che all'interno di questa
narrazione e lui con questi con questo
foglietto che ha un simbolo a cui questa
narrazione attribuisce valore ci può
pagare altri beni o servizi non finisce
qui le storie sono anche alla base del
nostro processo decisionale
leggete questa questa frase che è di
daniel kahneman già citato oggi nessuno
ha mai preso una decisione basandosi sui
numeri hanno tutti bisogno di una storia
da né daniel cane man è uno psicologo
che ha preso il premio nobel per
l'economia proprio elaborando questa sua
teoria che le persone non scelgono in
base a una valutazione re dei costi e
benefici reali ma piuttosto in base ad
una narrazione che si sono fatti del
mondo
e qui arriviamo al vero argomento del
mio ted di stasera perché a volte le
storie ci raccontano un mondo che non è
proprio adeguato a come il mondo
realmente è e per raccontarvi per
parlarvi di questa cosa vi voglio
raccontare
ovviamente una storia è una storia vera
è una storia drammatica ed è una storia
che io non riesco mai a raccontare senza
ridere quindi spero che nessuno se la
prenda questa è la storia del nostro
edgar welch edgar welch nel 2016 entra
in questa pizzeria di washington dc il
comet pizza ping pong dove si mangia la
pizza e si gioca a ping pong armato di
un fucile a ripetizione un fucile a
pompa e due pistole
comincia a sparare in aria gridando che
vuole vedere dove la cantina dove
tengono segregati i bambini
dopo un'ora e mezza di terrore esce da
quella pizzeria fortunatamente senza
aver sparato a nessuno profondamente
deluso non solo non ha trovato i bambini
segregati ma ha scoperto che in quella
pizzeria non c'è neanche una cantina
viene arrestato dalla polizia che
ovviamente lo interroga per capire che
cosa diavolo stia succedendo e questa è
la storia incredibile che lui racconta
qualche mese prima dei degli hacker sono
entrati nel server delle email hillary
clinton hanno rubato 30.000 email dal
server e gli hanno pure hanno pubblicate
in un forum di cui il nostro edgar fa
parte all'interno del forum la gente
comincia a leggere le email e a notare
che alcune parole si ripetono tra queste
parole che si ripetono ci sono queste
due cise pizza la passione di hillary
clinton per la pizza al formaggio
si mettono in testa all'interno di quel
forum che tra queste parole che si
ripetono ci sia un codice nascosto e per
che cosa mai postare ci spezza se non
per cp ovvero children pornography pedo
pornografia
perché la pizza però si chiedono
all'interno di quel forum chi è il
principale finanziatore del partito
democratico americano che vive a
washington dc come hillary clinton e che
ha a che fare con la pizza lo sfortunato
proprietario del comet pizza ping pong
la storia che nasce da quel forum e che
porta il nostro edgar a fare 600
chilometri in macchina ad entrare armato
in quella pizzeria è la seguente
i principali esponenti del partito
democratico americano bill clinton e
ovviamente hillary clinton bill gates
barack obama oprah winfrey la sera la
notte si trovano all'interno del comet
pizza ping pong per scambiarsi dei
bambini con i quali soddisfare le
proprie più bieche pulsioni sessuali ma
soprattutto per estrarne il sangue e con
un rito satanico farne il siero per la
vita eterna
meraviglioso quanto incredibilmente
diverse sono le due storie che vi ho
raccontato quella di darwin è quella di
edgar per nulla le le due cose che vi ho
raccontato sono identiche edgar si è
messo di fronte alla complessità delle
mail di hillary clinton la sua mente ha
selezionato alcuni tratti distintivi in
base alla sua curiosità li ha ordinati
in un in un pensiero chiaro una
narrazione che ha prodotto del senso il
cui scopo era la predittività
darwin con questo strumento ha prodotto
una narrazione che non solo si è
dimostrata predittiva del mondo darvin
ha visto la farfalla senza vederla ma
che è che ha creato una narrazione
talmente potente che ha scalfito la
narrazione precedente riguarda la
domanda più importante che noi ci siamo
mai fatti e cioè da dove diavolo veniamo
prima di darvi la risposta era d'addio
dal soffio divino da dopo darwin la
risposta e dalle scimmie
contemporaneamente edgar con lo stesso
strumento
ha preso una narrazione che si è
dimostrata incapace di prevedere la
realtà è che la anche fatto finire in
galera e gli ha fatto rischiare di
uccidere degli innocenti
la domanda che io stasera vi faccio è
perché
io stasera ci voglio provare a dare una
risposta a questa domanda se voleste
partecipare a questa mia ricerca questo
il mio sito internet è lo storytelling
puntoit slash pizza ho fatto una pagina
in cui potete scrivermi solo di questa
cosa qui andiamo avanti perché io ci
voglio provare
hunt orniamo a darwin darwin ha creato
la sua narrazione del mondo mescolando
due ingredienti il primo la sua
esperienza diretta del mondo lui era in
madagascar ha visto il fiore il secondo
ingrediente sono i suoi studi di
biologia sulla scienza e devo fare una
brevissima digressione restate con me la
scienza è un modo che noi abbiamo di
creare delle narrazioni sul mondo che ha
una particolarità e cioè un sistema di
controllo dell'adeguatezza delle storie
delle narrazioni che crea rispetto alla
realtà darwin con questi ingredienti ha
prodotto una narrazione funzionante
contemporaneamente
edgar all'interno del forum della pizza
ha creato un assemblato di storie fatte
da altre persone che partecipavano a
quel forum ha prodotto una specie di
frankenstein narrativo che si è
dimostrato inadeguato a descrivere la
realtà
e qui una domanda dovrebbe nascere
spontanea ma non se n'è accorto
e qui vi devo dire una cosa che non
avete voglia di sentire ma ve la dico lo
stesso ve lo dico prima nel modo più
complicato e poi ve la spiego in un modo
più semplice per il nostro cervello non
c'è differenza tra ciò che è vero e ciò
che è verosimile ciò che sembra vero per
la cosa che vi ho spiegato all'inizio la
la materia prima di cui è fatta la
nostra esperienza del mondo è di fatto
una storia
e noi il nostro cervello non distingue
tra una storia che è vera è una storia
che è falsa se questa è ben costruita e
socialmente condivisa
la verità è un effetto del senso delle
nostre storie
e qui arriviamo ad un'altra cosa che non
avete voglia di sentire e che vi
racconto lo stesso
quando noi troviamo una storia che è ben
raccontata e socialmente condivisa
tendiamo ad abbracciarla a non lasciarlo
andare neanche quando questa si dimostra
inadeguata a descrivere la realtà ed è
esattamente quello che è successo con il
forum della pizza voi pensereste che nel
momento in cui darwin scusate in cui
edgar
viene arrestato ed escono le sue
interviste in cui lui dice ragazzi non
c'era non c'era la la cantina non
c'erano i bambini all'interno del forum
la gente si guarda e si dica ragazzi
abbiamo fatto una cazzata chiudiamo il
forum ovviamente questo non è successo
da una costola di quel forum è nata la
piu grande teoria cospirazionista oggi
esistente al mondo che peraltro ha
inglobato il povero edgar che di colpo è
diventato un informatore dell fbi ma
questa è un'altra storia
e da questa teoria cospirazionista è
uscito lui ve lo ricordate lui jake
angeli il principale agitatore delle
proteste del campidoglio dopo la
sconfitta di trump alle elezioni
americane
se non vi fosse arrivato con la potenza
che questa cosa ha
lasciate che ve lo ripete in un'altra
maniera
il più clamoroso attentato nella più
grande democrazia alla più grande
democrazia del mondo fortunatamente
mancato è stato protratto da un gruppo
di persone convinte che obama di notte
andasse a fare riti satanici
nella cantina inesistente di una
pizzeria dove si gioca a ping pong
due cose vorrei che mi portasse a casa
da questo tetto
la prima è di non sottovalutare mai una
storia
per quanto buffo strampalata vi sembri
non sottovalutate mai una storia la
seconda cosa che vorrei che vi portate a
casa la seguente noi abbiamo un problema
con le nostre storie non con tutte le
nostre storie ma con alcune delle nostre
storie abbiamo un problema
è questo problema sarà il problema
principale secondo me che dovremo
affrontare nei prossimi venti o
trent'anni quando dico principale non
intendo che il più grande intendo che è
quello che dobbiamo affrontare per primo
perché come vi ho spiegato le cose che
vi ho spiegato all'inizio saltano tutte
nel momento in cui le nostre storie non
sono adeguate a descrivere la realtà
salta il tessuto sociale
salta la nostra capacità predittiva
salta la nostra capacità di inquadrare i
problemi e alla fine di tutto questo
salta la nostra capacità di adattarsi
all'ambiente e quindi di evolverci
grazie a tutti